bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette dernière
édition de la saison du cette suite
après plus de 175 numéro nous allons
refaire mais cette année avec un focus
sur vos activités de l'été invités de ce
12 juillet des animateurs du château de
breteuil mais également le cofondateur
de black blanc beur la troupe de
danseurs hip hop pour nous parler de ses
derniers projets on commence donc cette
édition par la page culture
et jean djemaa de bonsoir bonsoir est
donc le cofondateur de black blanc beur
administrateur de production également
la troupe la création remonte à 1984 et
dès le début l'objectif c'était la
mixité sociale la mixité culturelle et
ça n'a pas changé aujourd'hui encore
vous développer ce type de projet depuis
deux ans vous avez créé un spectacle
vous êtes en train de créer un spectacle
avec des jeunes en voie de
professionnalisation
absolument c'est un travail de
nombreuses années puisque une des
particularités de notre travail c'est
d'abord une autre particularité c'est
d'être des habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines qui sont devenus artistes
il ya eu des conditions exceptionnelles
qui ont permis cette sorte de
construction et aujourd'hui nous paraît
fondamental de ne pas être simplement
prestataire ou de sensibiliser
simplement mais d'accompagner des désirs
de de faire de l'art et là en
l'occurrence il s'agit de danseurs de
deux danseuses de trappes que nous avons
revu pendant une quinzaine d'années à
l'instar d'un certain nombre de projets
sur un an deux ans trois ans et qui sont
effectivement aujourd'hui arriver à un
niveau de
préprofessionnalisation
pour lequel nous sommes en train de
concevoir une création c'est à dire
quelque chose qui est un petit peu plus
que les ateliers qu'on fait
habituellement et qui est véritablement
une manière de mettre en forme ce qu'ils
ont envie de dire alors qu ont-ils envie
de dire je vais pas faire une paraphrase
merdique puisque l'intérêt du spectacle
justement c'est de l'éviter mais en gros
si tu es la thématique ils sont partis
sur la notion de riches et de pauvres
alors de qui sommes-nous le riche de qui
sommes-nous le pauvre c'est vraiment
tout un travail sur le paradoxe de cette
notion à une époque où dans leur
situation de jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans
dans leur situation devenir de milieux
populaires de classe moyenne de d'une
ville comme trappe ou d'une communauté
comme saint quentin en yvelines l'eure
fait se poser une multitude de questions
d'avenir et parfois avoir aussi un
regard
comment dirais-je
un peu jaloux parfois un peu envieux sur
ce qu'il considère comme les riches donc
nous sommes en train de fouiller la
question ait eu de nombreuses étapes
nous sommes maintenant dans la
deuxième phase la troisième phase aura
lieu l'année prochaine nous avons à peu
près 20 minutes de matière ça commençait
à peu près deux ans ça commence très
près voilà 18 mois disons d'abord saison
2 saison mise à niveau tout départ mise
à niveau technique ni toi la variété des
différences stylistiques parce qu on a
essentiellement par un chez les garçons
débreaker chez les filles des danseuses
de boue donc nous avons fait passer un
certain nombre d'intervenants qui
montrait toute cette diversité
stylistique et puis au fur et à mesure
il ya eu tout un travail aussi de
réflexion sur la thématique est sûre en
gros comment on part d'une idée pour que
à l'arrivée ce soit de la danse sur un
plateau voilà cette phase jeu les animer
avec les intervenants les différents
professeurs et christine a pris le
relais depuis le mois de mai dernier
pour passer maintenant véritablement à
la phase de restitution et d'écriture là
je pense qu'elle est vraiment en phase
de pouvoir mettre en forme un scénario
mais voyez le paradoxe de ce type de
démarche de co construction c'est que on
n'a pas les choses à l'avance par
exemple c'est pas nous qui décidons d'un
titre avant de partir alors il fallait
bien nommé le projet donc moi je les
intitulés eh bien dansez maintenant mais
c'était une manière de m'adresser à eux
et j'espère que la réponse donner les
clés pour que d'autres produisent
quelque chose et ils sont visiblement en
bonne voix libérez moi c'était super
deviennent des danseurs professionnels
alors il ya beaucoup d'entre eux sont
déjà en mesure je pense de faire des
remplacements ou de travailler en tant
que professionnel mais je pense que ça
va être effectivement le parcours
initiatique qui va leur ouvrir les
portes bien entendu notre compagnie et
j'espère de l'ensemble alors le marché
n'est pas le mot le plus approprié mais
enfin en tout cas de cet espace des
changes qui va leur permettre aussi
d'aller acquérir d'autres expériences il
y aura notamment l'année prochaine la
venue sur le territoire de rom ul et de
gilles rondeau qui à travers une
opération menée par la communauté
d'agglo vont offrir une série de stages
ils vont naturellement y participer
ainsi que les amateurs auxquels nous
sommes régulièrement
confrontés sur trappe notamment avec le
service jeunesse donc c'était important
pour une compagnie comme la nôtre de
reconstituer une base d'amateurs une
base d'amateurs habitants et puis
un espace intermédiaire de jeunes
professionnels à qui nous avons à offrir
bien sûr des savoir faire mais aussi un
répertoire
c'est à dire des oeuvres dans lesquelles
ils vont pouvoir se roder s'éroder sa
s'altérer voilà le travail avec cet
arrêté parce qu on approche des vacances
voilà alors il termine demain un stage
de quinze jours qui a été vraiment
intensif et qui était vraiment fondées
comme je l'indiqué sur l'écriture et la
réalisation du scénario ils sont cette
année ils étaient à deux séances par
semaine deux séances de trois heures
nous allons je l'espère conserver ce
rythme tout au long de l'année 2013 et
aboutir une
représentation d' environ prévus pour
environ une heure
je pense dernier trimestre 2013 là je
viens à l'instant de la mjc deux abribus
de bois d'arcy où les probables par
exemple que nous aurons une présentation
d'un travail intermédiaires le 25 mai
donc ça nous ferons savoir d'ici là mais
l'idée c'est quand même de profiter de
notre présence départementales et
régionales pour faire circuler les
différents groupes avec lesquels nous
travaillons notamment poissy mantes la
jolie
voilà j'en oubliais et là on est
vraiment dans le coeur du métier de
black blanc beur pas forcément de
produire des productions
professionnelles des spectacles mais
vraiment de s'adresser de transformation
de transmettre un savoir-faire de
transmettre un niveau une exigence et
puis de ramener en permanence la
pratique a un sens ce qui fait peut-être
la distinction entre une pratique de
loisir et un à la suite pour vous dans
cet été alors il reprend avec tout le
monde mais non c'est vrai alors c'est un
peu de repos cet été puisque on vient de
terminer une pièce qui s'appelle inside
que nous allons présenter je pense en
avril prochain les dates commence à
s'affiner mais je préfère me pas encore
en parler parce que ça n'ait pas décidé
définitivement mais ça sera à au ceat et
eurydice de plaisir ou probablement vers
la mi avril nous allons présenter donc
le spectacle s'appelle inside et qui est
un spectacle commandes initialement sur
le thème de la drogue et des addictions
alors ce spectacle est ciblée sur les
adolescents notamment les collégiens et
la voilà un travail pour lequel nous
avons mis christine a mis dix ans à
savoir comment elle allait traiter ce
sujet là parce que c'est facilement un
sujet sur lequel on peut être donneur de
leçons moraliste ou anecdotiques bon je
pense qu'elle a trouvé une forme de
danse théâtre quelque chose qui en
revisitant l'ensemble des états du corps
addicts du corps
dépendant permet avec beaucoup d'humour
en empruntant les langages de la
consommation les langages j'allais dire
presque de tf1
de repro blé matiz est complètement
7,7 ce type d'histoire et surtout de
faire prendre une distance propice à une
prise de conscience et c'est ce que nous
espérons au mieux c'est à dire que y ait
une sorte de déclic une sorte de
réflexion ces travaux vont être
accompagnée d'ateliers aussi en collège
ou
dans le milieu associatif ouvert qui
précéderont ou qui suivront les
représentations de ce spectacle là aussi
rien de tel que d'y coller son propre
corps beaucoup travaillent pour vous à
la rentrée activité toujours très chargé
pour la nouille de blagues longueur
merci sentir c'est moi qui est revenu
sur ce plateau cette dernière de la
saison parlé un petit peu du travail que
vous avez menées au cours de cette année
encore merci aux films nous allons
continuer cette édition du 7 8 et parler
à présent des activités de l'été